oder ist das wieder so eine situation
ein wunderschöner sonnigen mittag
erwartet uns hier auf unserer karte der
tintenfisch dahinten genießt auch die
sonnenstrahlen aus dem wasser und du das
wissen wir langsam mir wurde in meinem
letzten video und in die kommentare
geschrieben dass das was ich hier gerade
mit der schaufel mache angeblich eine
art weg sei und das wird in village an
von in villages in das wird vielen
dörfern von village unangewendet also
von dorfbewohnern und damit wollen die
wohl irgendwelche wege zeigen markieren
whatever von daher würde ich sagen
machen wir uns damit hier auch so einen
kleinen weg der dann dort hinten zum
wasser führt und dann vom wasser aus zu
einem ja hier können wir jetzt nicht
mehr so richtig weiter
na wie geht's ja die haben wir jetzt auf
jeden fall einen kleinen süßen weg da
können wir jetzt noch ein paar fackeln
an rand irgendwie machen und vor allem
auch unsere setzlinge mal platzieren
weil irgendwie geht unsere ganze insel
ja doch so ein wenig auseinander gerupft
auswendig von einer hier vorne ein
setzling hin hier können wir auch noch
einen packen dann haben wir so ein paar
bäumchen ich glaube es ist auch heute an
der zeit den baum hier mal ab zu fällen
oder was sagst du dazu ich will dir
gleich mal deinen kopf ab du penner
wir setzen hier auf jeden fall ja
irgendwo anders wieder hin von daher
habe ich den jetzt erst mal weg da steht
halt immer so ein bisschen im weg wenn
man bei mir in die bude rein will und
das hat mir auch einige geschrieben hier
soll ein bisschen glas rein also okay
wie die ubi gewollt da können jetzt mal
ein bisschen sand zu glas werden lassen
wir noch einige gefragt wo ich hier
gerade pepper herlaufen sehr gut
geschrieben dass ich für meine tiere
doch bitte einen stall anfertigen soll
ich bin da allerdings ganz ehrlich die
tiere die ich hier habe dann möchte ich
wirklich dass sie frei herumlaufen
können dass sie sich wohlfühlen und das
dann nicht irgendwie die eingesperrt
sind oder so ich meine dadurch dass ich
mich komplett vegetarischen dem projekt
hier ernähren möchte ist es
nicht so dass ich jetzt unbedingt die
kühe brauche für das fleisch und für das
leder und so weiter und so fort wir
gucken jetzt allerdings erst mal bei
unserem glas ihr vorbei das ist perfekt
denn ich wollte hier auch glasscheiben
machen der unterschied zwischen normal
bei der tastatur spinnt eine tastatur
kann automatisch gelaufen der
unterschied zwischen normalem glas und
diesen glasscheiben das einfach dass ich
jetzt ein bisschen filigraner so ein
bisschen schicker aussehen und dann
könnte ich auch noch eine fackel
hinhängen gibt sich neuerdings auch
laternen in minecraft da brauchen wir
eisenführ ich würde allerdings sagen
dass wir uns heute erst mal an etwas
setzen was viele von euch in die
kommentare geschrieben haben und zwar
sind hat es erhalten und zwar das etwas
mit diesem brötchen hier zu tun denn
einige haben in die kommentare
geschrieben hey luca wir können es gar
nicht abwarten bis hin zu den anderen
inseln oberförster ersetze ich hier
schon mal ein kleines bildchen hin ich
wollte auch von kleinen steg zum boot
machen ob wir
ich bin 0 ausgerüstet
hey willst du vielleicht mal wieder mit
ihr hoch kommen da irgendwie hochlaufen
ich nehme jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal
ein bisschen cobblestone mit dem brauche
ich nehme ich mir gleich eine schaufel
zu machen mit der schaufel mache ich den
weg weiter zu unserem boot seiner ach
guck ma jetzt plötzlich ist auch okay
für die ja generell freut wichtig
resonanz für diese videos einfach extrem
also das macht mir total viel spaß
dieses produkt ihr produkt bin ich los
dieses projekt macht mir auf jeden fall
extrem viel spaß und das wird umso
schöner durch eure ganzen lieben netten
kommentare tipps und tricks die ihr mir
immer unten rein schreibt hier würde ich
sagen machen wir morgen weiter ich gehe
jetzt erstmal hinten schlafen hier
ich kann doch nichts dafür dass du die
ganze zeit fressen will ist schön wieder
aufgewacht hier vorne ein neuer tag
beginnt das schweinchen ist hier vorne
erst mal auch ein bisschen getrockneten
seetang rein da wurden wir auch ganz
viele kommentare geschrieben dass das
eigentlich kein allzu gutes
nahrungsmittel ist weil es halt nicht so
viel auffüllt vom leben und da muss ich
mich leider zustimmen das stimmt ja also
so viel hunger filtert ging wirklich
nicht auf die sache ist allerdings dass
ich halt gerade aktuell nichts anderes
habe klar macht brot da deutlich mehr
sinn
aber schauen wir einfach mal das
entwickelt sich ja hier und ich habe ja
auch in der letzten folge schon gesagt
mir ist hier geschwindigkeit nicht so
wichtig das einzige was für mich das
meinten auch einige dass sich die
schildkröten vermehren lassen kann das
will ich doch nicht egal ich hab doch
schon 10.000 ich würde allerdings sagen
wir setzen uns jetzt erstmal unser
brötchen und fahren dort vorne auf die
insel rüber denn ich brauche erde und
ich will nicht bei unserer insel noch
mehr erde abtragen außer vielleicht von
unserem haus das könnte ich echt eine
etage tiefer setzen auf jeden fall sind
wir jetzt hier in dieser neuen insel
angekommen langsam halten
die frage ist was ich hier auf uns
wartet dahin ist sogar noch eine nächste
insel das nur ein bisschen zuckerrohr
hier haben wir so einen kleinen
plus bzw einen kleinen kleinen tümpel er
die blumen hier wollte ich auf jeden
fall mitnehmen für das grab dass ich
wieder so ein bisschen hinsetzen kann
dann können wir auch hier vorne mal das
zuckerrohr mitnehmen so ein bisschen
setzlinge werden auf jeden fall auch
noch cool ich habe mich auch ganz doll
informiert über farben und so die
mannschaft bauen kann
für die meisten fahren was zumindest
jupiter angeht braucht man jedoch
westens und südwestens braucht man
redstone und für redstone muss man in
höhlen gehen ist hier vorne der höhle
vielleicht sieht auch aus wieder wie so
ein tümpel
ich weiß auf jeden fall erstmal noch ein
bisschen erde ab die brauchen wir
nämlich um unsere ganze creeper löcher
auszustopfen die schaufel ist kaputt ich
idiot habe natürlich keine zweite
gemacht ich glaube allerdings erst mal
dass auch anderthalb stacks erde reichen
sollten dementsprechend schwingen bei
uns beziehen unser brötchen und fahr mal
wieder zurück auf unsere insel so einmal
zurück auspacken und jetzt wieder da
vorne hin
es ist schon schön aus allerdings ist
wirklich unser haus ein bisschen zu hoch
finde ich das schweinchen steht nach
vorne auch schon ne ja und wir halten
jetzt hier ganz gediegen wieder an
unserem steg springen hier darauf die
schildkröten und dann auch spaß
von daher würde ich tatsächlich sagen
fangen wir sogar hier direkt an ich weiß
natürlich jetzt nicht wie ich das alles
haben möchte ich weiß nicht wo ich den
strand haben möchte ich kann mir das
hier komplett ausland machen kommen das
machen was macht
dort wo kommen diese plötzlich her wo
kommt der ddr und vox ich habe mich
gerade mal erst gar nicht sind ja seit
packard läuft ja einfach rum geht in
meiner farm elfter hochkommt seine
alpakas team hinterher oder was ich
keine ahnung kann mir bitte mal jemand
von euch in die kommentare schreiben
woher der plötzlich kommt mit seiner
alpakas wir machen unser projekt einfach
mal weiter lassen uns davon nicht
beeindrucken
ich möchte hier vorne den sand hinsetzen
und das ist für heute auch das ziel die
insel reparatur in meiner lieben freunde
so niemand in sand setzen ihr vorne hin
ich mache hier außer immer wieder kurze
time lassen
so haben wir alles auf jeden fall schon
mal ein bisschen schöner hier dass sie
muss natürlich auch die läufe
automatisch meinem das ist der mit
meiner tastatur los wenn wir auf jeden
fall alles wieder so ein bisschen
schöner
ich setze jetzt auch einfach mal kurz so
eine fackel hin damit wir so ein
bisschen licht haben ich würde gerne auf
der erde kann ich das nicht mein gott ja
ich weiß dass du süß willst aber ich
habe mich trotzdem erschrocken
egal ob du manfred rein wunderschön und
erst wieder da wahnsinn ein
wunderschöner neuer tag der baum ist
gewachsen und der dorfbewohner das
wieder da ja auch um die schönen morgen
die ich bei unseren steht hier unten auf
jeden fall noch so ein kleines stückchen
weiter dass er bis hier vorne auf jeden
fall übergeht das ist glaube ich ganz
schön dann schließt er direkt mit dem
mit der erde hier an so zack zack zack
zack zack und was ich mir auch gerade
gedacht habe war anstatt dass sie die
fackeln so stumpf rumstehen vielleicht
eine kleine steinmauer und noch
vielleicht da und hier nur noch hier
dennoch rief vorne
und dann noch hier oder so dann kann ich
jetzt theoretisch nämlich die fackel
nehmen einfach ich spiele das zum ersten
mal seit einem jahr die sache ist ich
brauche jetzt halt unbedingt mal
irgendwelche materialien ich kratze
immer noch rum mit irgendwelchen holz
gegen oder das stein gegenständen
also müssen uns auf jeden fall der höhle
suchen was hast du dazu ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich glaube ich freue mich jetzt
einfach mal runter ich brauche mich hier
einfach runter das ist mir egal ich mag
das eigentlich nicht wenn man den
minecraft so standardmäßig irgendwie
meinen geht allerdings brauchen wir das
einfach so und jetzt nicht mehr wir
brauchen rohstoffe wir haben keine
richtige insel auf keine richtige höhle
auf unserer insel wollte ich sagen wir
gehen jetzt einfach mal runter auf eine
höhe wo eisen
aber so einfach geht ich höre gerade
extrem viele monster ich habe keine
ahnung ob das eine gute idee ist dass
ich das er gerade mache aber ein
bisschen stress habe ich eigentlich sind
dass ich mich hier gerade runter baue
oder ist das wieder so eine situation
die sache ist okay okay okay okay okay
cha cha cha cha cha cha cha ganz
entspannt wollte ich mir einfach links
suchen hier sollen
sondern so eingang irgendwie hier unten
machen wo ich dann irgendwie habe ich
das dritte schwert ich bin auch nervös
nicht zum eisen bruder nicht das eisen
kaputt machen
[Musik]
ich bin doch immer so equipped wie soll
unser alltag ist auch so ein riesenloch
aber das sind auf jeden fall ein paar
tipps und dessen nicht sein ernst
ich muss dir direkt wieder weg
ich musste direkt wieder weg ich muss
einfach nur meine items sichern ich
nehme jetzt mal die eisen achse wieder
gemerkt habt wichtiger des lebens sind
tot
was will ich muss ich das jetzt hier
nicht abrufen
ich würde an der stelle die heutige
wieso gemeinschaft mit luca auch beenden
wollte ich vorhin sagen meine lieben
freunde
ich weiß es ist jetzt ein kleiner blogs
wird dass sich ihr vorderrad die folge
beendet
wo wir instant jetzt gerade in eine
höhle gefunden haben und jetzt irgendwie
gerade hier voll mega krank was abgeht
die sache ist allerdings dass mir das
gerade ein bisschen zu viel ist und ich
musste erst mal kurz ein bisschen
chillen
ich muss auch glaube ich erst einmal
nach oben gehen wir ein bisschen das
leben ausfüllen wie haben jetzt auf
jeden fall hier unten unsere kleine base
wir haben auch hier holz drin das ist
perfekt weil daraus werde ich mir jetzt
komplett leitern machen
[Musik]
tja kommt wohl nicht hoch früher konnte
man nur alle zwei stufenleiter setzen
dann konnte man so ein bisschen leid
ersparen
allerdings hat sich mein gold sehr stark
verändert und es reicht aber trotzdem
nicht ganz aber wir können zumindest
hier so ein bisschen uns dann raus
nicken
hier setzt wie eine fackel hin damit wir
das nicht das ist ja schon ein bisschen
selbstmord ihr damit wir das auf jeden
fall nicht vergessen
ich glaube dass wir auf gar keinen fall
vergessen nehmen wir noch kurz unsere
schaufel und machen hier den weg so ein
bisschen weiter dann haben das nämlich
jetzt weil wir schon mal hier so ein
bisschen können wir entspannt hochlaufen
der bekommen sich natürlich ein bisschen
blöd aus aber nur damit ihr wäre mein
gott habe ich ja gar nicht gesehen
de gier macht mir nicht schon wieder
meine insel kaputt macht mir nicht schon
wieder meine insel kaputt dass sie nicht
zu bekommen
das lasse ich nicht zu der kommt immer
dahin wo die ganzen
links sind chor der skeptiker um ein
gott ein herz ein herziger ich muss
jedoch ein bisschen auslöschen das hat
mir auch fielen die kommentare
geschrieben der keeper kommt von da
hinten wieder
ich habe ein herziger ich habe ein herz
ich kann ganz schnell versuchen noch ein
verrottetes fleisch zu essen
oh mein gott okay und wir sehen die
sonne geht auf meine lieben freunde das
heißt wir haben diese folge auch gekonnt
überlegt hat was gesagt ja auch besser
so die nächste folge wird auf jeden fall
eine riesige höhlen folge wir werden uns
also nur in der höhle aufhalten werden
ordentlich farben gehen wir werden
monster töten diamanten finden hoffe ich
wäre hast mich an geschubst daher ist es
doch nicht sein ernst oder schauen was
soll das wenn euch die heutige episode
minecraft mit luca gefallen hat das
gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem video
er da schreibt mir gern tipps und tricks
und dinge die ich generell in diesem
projekt machen und umsetzen sollten in
die kommentare abonniert neuen kanal
wenn ihr die neue voll gemeinschaft mit
luca nicht verpassen wollte und die
kommt übermorgen um 20 uhr auf einem
kanal
[Musik]